is an 8 news now breaking news alert
breaking news off the top here at five
o'clock ccsd police telling us they have
arrested a school employee here's a
photo of 42 year old willie price books
junior accused of attempted sexual
misconduct thanks for joining us here at
five i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis victoria saha is learning he was
a coach at desert oasis high school
that's where we find victoria now
joining us live
after checking the athletic department's
website we learned 42-year-old willie
price brooks jr was the head coach here
head coach for the girls basketball team
here at desert oasis high school
a short time ago school police released
a booking photo of price brooks earlier
this month a 17-year-old female student
at the school reported the attempted
sexual misconduct prompting the
investigation price brooks has been
employed by the school district since
2014 but now his status has been
terminated price brooks made an
appearance in justice court this
afternoon and posted his bill he's
expected to be back in front of a judge
february 16. if you have any information
about this case or anyone who had
inappropriate conduct to please call
police reporting live from desert oasis
high school victoria zaha live local now